most of the crash dangers happen during
Landing or like one of the when when the
malfunctions happen bro when they land
it feels like they haven't worked out
all the Kinks yet like sometimes it it
does it's too loud and it makes me too
nervous when we land you know what's
funny it's interesting that the higher
rate of failure is when the plane
becomes a car
[Laughter]
[Music]
again so have you guys been flying
around recently using airplanes and
stuff like that don't tell me I got
cancer you have cancer Jo [__] if you
recently were on a plane you would now
have cancer yeah is class blue s BL no
so check this
out the biggest US airlines are
searching for thousands of jet engine
parts with fake safety certificates that
were installed on their planes wow I'm
talking about the big boys I'm talking
about American Airlines united Southwest
Delta dude I fly American do budget then
wow the budget even planes are faking
smog chests so I know right there's a
there's a a uh a broker of Airline partk
called AOG Technics and there's been a
lawsuit filed by General Electric and
their engine partner and they say that
the the company used large scale
falsification of documentation to sell
engine parts to Airlines so they're
ducking yeah a lot of the safety
concerns they have an entire apparatus
for like double checking and triple
checking like these parts before they
get to these planes uh on these PL so
they just [__] were able to weasel
through the double checking and the
triple cheing safety Parts why couldn't
it just be like the toilet lever or
something it was all so these spare
parts were supplied with false
certification documents and uh now all
these airlines are trying to basically
go through and check all their parts and
see which ones do the savings get passed
down to you because of that nope only to
death nope this is like the scariest
[__] I've ever heard right can you
imagine like what if we start
experiencing Mass like Airline accidents
holy [__] Mass Airline accidents I put
this article in yesterday before I got
into a Delta flight oh my God was that
scary it was scary especially cuz it was
making you know I'm sure it was making
the same noise it always makes but I'm
like it doesn't normally make that noise
you
should anytime you land I'm like I
always prepare myself to be like we
might die do you clap when you land they
used to do that a lot don't do that cuz
if the four big ones have it all of them
have it yeah I mean that's crazy well if
turbulence is really bad I have been on
some planes that clapped cuz the
turbulence was so nuts yeah and they
didn't say United right maybe United
paid for this article oh you think so
yeah American Delta who else American
United Southwest Delta Southwest
everybody but flying is super super
super safe because of how many checks
they do it's actually more dangerous to
drive but we're just more afraid of but
that might be the statistic before they
had fake Parts yeah but you know what it
is too now we got fake parts that's a
big variable change statistics when
every time somebody says that to me I
just think about okay cool but if I get
in a car accident I could live you could
live yeah for me if you're in the plane
and then dude you ever think about like
how long it takes to hit the ground and
like that [__] mind [__] the Free
Fall you're just screaming for like 5
minutes dude did you guys
hear like that that's my face so so a
typical flight's like like 30,000 ft
right yeah so remember when um we were
kids but in the 1980s the Challenger um
spacial
like got destroyed right one of the most
[__] up things that the media never
said about that incident is that the
astronaut survived the the explosion the
safety capsule was jettisoned and they
all were just in freeall for minutes and
minutes and minutes because they were so
high up in the atmosphere yeah holy [__]
that's like free sky so the impact of
the Fall is what killed him that's what
killed him it wasn't the the what I
never knew that I know dude it's one of
those my God God yeah and so like being
in freef Fall for like I don't know 10
minutes I make the best out of it 10
minutes what what would you do I'd start
spinning and trying to squirrel suit
style [__] so the protocol that thing it
jettison itself and it's supposed to
have a
shoot I I don't know what the deal is
with it like I don't know that it was
like the shoot malfunction or anything
like that I just know that they they
were in freef fall and that's what the
impact is what killed them cuz they they
they had they they recovered the capsule
like that
I heard that right before you even hit
the ground though the pressure you die
it'd be like Sandra Bullock and gravity
the end is just she dies basically yeah
she got really lucky in that water yeah
like of course you're going to [__]
survive Landing in the water with no
[__] everything and George Clooney is
like faking your head like come on
spoiler he was faking your head the
whole time really that's a good twist
most of the crash dangers happen during
Landing or like one of the when when the
malfunctions happen cuz the wheels or
whatever but then and in the air they
say it's really [__] safe because
there's a lot of fail proofs bro when
they land it feels like they haven't
worked out all the Kinks yet like
sometimes it it does it's too loud and
it makes me too nervous when we land you
know what's funny it's interesting that
the higher rate of failure is when the
plane becomes a car
again right yeah blows out a tire oh
that's not a plane crash it's not a
plane CR cuz in the air they have
backups to
backups like they have a lot of
redundancies cuzz it's like if this
engine fails they have this uh and then
or like if this piece fails and then
they have this or whatever so well and
both engines can fail and it's
aerodynamic enough where you could maybe
that's what I heard about propeller can
it won't just like like just nose dive I
mean i' I don't know about in with the
big heavy planes but with small planes
definitely it's like a glider yeah I was
recently on my way back from Vegas this
past weekend and uh I was [__] up so I
was like trying to
sleep I just saw him you were in Vegas
yeah yeah you're never in Vegas I just
got back well you missed his freaking
valow renewal thing I didn't know
not anyways so I was on my cut that out
so I was on my way back from Vegas and
you know I was [__] up so I was like
sleeping and maybe I'm just used to
flights like that but there was
apparently a lot of turbulence and Nina
the whole time was squeezing the [__]
out of my hand and like looking out the
windows if you could do anything and I
was just
like but you know when you're like in
turbulence and you're just used to it
don't you kind of like oh because you
fly so much yeah don't you like not care
anymore I don't even care at all yeah
yeah but like people who are rarely
flying turbulence [__] you up for sure
like everything about your experience
but [__] just be scared yeah [__]
be tripping [__] be tripping the the
turbulence that like drops like 4 feet
randomly gets me still yeah that that's
like a Tower of Terror that's a roller
coaster if if your gut goes up here no
matter what you're going to get hit when
Tiff starts tripping about turbulence I
tell her I'm like look babe there's
nothing we could do if we crash we crash
die exactly what they want to hear I was
like babe that's it we just let go do
you close the seat Bel a bit more N I
just try to let go just you just put the
oxygen mask on or just like I got to put
mine on first you should take off her
seat belt yeah like come on baby let him
fly with this news do you guys want to
fly less no for real I like Adventure it
doesn't surprise me I feel like even
back when we were flying years ago the
same [__] was probably happening Parts I
like knowing that they're on it but then
it makes it worries me that they weren't
on it yeah someone [__] up yeah
someone bypassed it's like should I go
to church after I find out they did a
bunch of kids I'm like you know at least
I know they're probably still going to
do
it so the the a US database of approvals
for parts like the on sold by this this
group um shows no record of the company
having received any approvals so that's
kind of how they were able to put
together what happened and now they're
just trying to go through and and almost
do a census of all their parts I read
that they started investigating and then
the company I think that made the all
the parts that company dissolves and
doesn't even exist anymore what so
they're trying to yeah they're trying to
like figure out like like who did this
like who's behind all this and this just
gone is that crazy some [__] crazy
[__] there's got to be way better
records for something so serious on the
yeah and
go the part for the engine Wing they
have and then they go
that's exactly how they do it you know
what they should get they should get the
system from AutoZone good system cuz
when you get to Auto Zone they got a
good system they really do though they
do cuz you could get it on their website
and then they'll when you show up the
parts are there or you go to the store
and you go I need WD40 and then they're
like we got 10 in stock you know what
sometimes sometimes it's not good cuz
sometimes I remember I went recently
when we had the [__] hurricane or
whatever a big deal and I need to switch
my windshield wipers out and I was like
hey can I can I can you tell me which
windshield wiper I need to get he goes
yeah what car do you have I I have a
Chevy Silver Rod and he
goes then he was like is it 26 in or 28
in windshield wipers and I'm like
shouldn't you know cuz I don't know how
why would I know that [__] yeah but
how the [__] am I you making fun of me
yeah I really like my windshield rers I
got now what' you get 26 to 28 I forgot
fck but it was like the extreme one how
bad do they hit each other when you use
you got one of each this one make you
guys feel better the most this will make
you guys feel better the most affected
engine model the cfm56 holds the record
for most aircraft engines ever sold with
over 33,000 of the turbines delivered to
customers since its entry to service in
1982 so that's like the most reliable
airplane motor that's the most affected
engine model in this Scandal that's the
yeah the one that everyone
uses well well that's good I fly
Hawaiian Airlines and that's not in
there what if the malfunctions aren't
that bad know huh what if the
malfunctions aren't that bad like what
if it yeah what if it's not that big
deal like we haven't seen any PL crash
Hawaiian Airlines uses the
cfm56 no I got to go Southwest
now Southwest he definitely named it
them
be probably every Airline one time on
Hawaiian Airlines we're flying into
Hawaii and just some smoke like a loud
bang popped as we're landing and then
the cabin started filling smoke no
[__] way and they're selling [__]
credit cards to us the captain's like
hey the captain's like don't forget the
spirit of Aloha yeah and he's [__]
yeah all the Ste are walking down like
oh would you like a pamphlet would you
like would you like one and then the
Hawaii fire department had to come they
didn't explain anything at all like oh
sorry about that guys he sounded nervous
we were all nervous that made me nervous
it was a Hawaiian Airlines flight that
had that recent crazy turb that have you
seen the
footage started with the flight
attendant looking like this with blood
dripping down her [__] skull I saw
lady hit the [__] top of the the tube
that's pretty rough faulty engine parts
right there that's the Denzel movie that
happened in that flight yeah same thing
oh Training Day yeah I feel like that's
the turbulence that our wives look at
and go see it can happen that's true and
I'm like love hearing that you should
wear a seat Bel yeah yeah what you doing
walking around the aisles idiot you know
but after that video though I started
wearing my seat belt when I slept I
think you have to Bro oh just in case uh
yeah yeah because what if you get that
kind of crazy turbulence and then you're
sleeping and you fly and you wake up
hitting the top of the [__] airplane
you got to do it like rying though where
you tuck your arms under the seat Bel so
you don't hit people while you sleep
yeah you got to make a straight jacket
you do that yeah cuz or else I'm going
to do this what the [__] you're popping
locking while you're sleeping what's
this the funk never
stops he breaks Dan in as sleep yeah I
have like weird like ticks where when I
sleep I can't keep a water bottle too
close to my nightstand cuz sometimes
I'll knock it over and then I waake wake
up and there's a [__] puddle ground
you're afraid for the water bottle what
about like Gio you're going to give her
a
[__] for some reason it only goes
this side if you hit somebody you don't
Smack smack no it only goes on my left
side it's only when I'm on a plane not
when I'm like laying this way it's only
when I'm on a plan I like start to do
this so then I put my arms in a thing
and I don't wake up the whole flight wow
I need do that so when you don't strap
yourself in do you wake yourself up by
throwing your arms around I do yeah or
someone else gets hit and they wake me
up I guarantee you the probability of is
so small it's just scary to think about
it but you're going to be okay but if
there's a bunch of disasters soon just
remember we broke the news here first
just kidding and if it does happen it's
even safer because you know the worst of
the luck just went through Joe can you
cut the ad for um to make everyone feel
better Joe from just kidy news on this
Airline thing hey if it happened already
that's the perfect time to fly because
it's going to be cheaper and then on top
of that probabilities are much lower
once it already happened just like when
you play roulette and what if it didn't
happen yet then what's the other
commercial don't be such a
[__] get on the flights die in the sky
like a man that's why this show is
[Music]
here